tras una semana de incertidumbre y
bloqueos en la frontera entre méxico y
el estado de texas en eeuu finalmente
reabrió después de que el gobernador
tejano gregg abbott decidiera revocar
las inspecciones de los camiones de
mercancía que impuso hace una semana
estamos formados desde muy temprano
haciendo fila para poder usar nuestras
exportaciones pero no no se ha movido
nada
abbott había ordenado estas inspecciones
para evitar así el ingreso de
inmigrantes indocumentados al país algo
que no convenció a los transportistas
por el retraso que esto supuso en su
trabajo por lo que se declararon en
huelga y bloquearon dos tránsito dos
puentes que unen ambos países hasta hoy
la medida tampoco convenció a la misma
casablanca que reportó en las cifras
negativas por el paro lo que estamos
viendo con estas inspecciones
innecesarias del transporte de camiones
que transitan por los puertos de entrada
entre texas y méxico son retrasos
significativos están dando lugar a una
caída comercial del 60 por ciento hasta
el 70 por ciento en algunos casos
vida valorada en 8 millones de dólares
que afectará sobre todo a las familias
de ambos lados de la frontera y estoy
segura de que es posible impulsar
mejores acciones para fortalecer la
seguridad de ambos lados de la frontera
sin afectar la economía de las familias
mexicanas y estadounidenses muchos
critican que en lugar de frenar la
migración lo que consiguió a bot que
busca la reelección como gobernador fue
boicotear la economía del estado méxico
y eeuu son importantes socios
comerciales que sólo en 2020
intercambiaron bienes y servicios con un
valor de casi 180 mil millones de
dólares